this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less
my name is joshua fields milburn and i'm
ryan nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists
today we're here with jamie wheel author
of the brand new book
recapture the rapture jamie
thank you for joining us today oh thanks
for having me guys well i'm holding up
the book here for youtube
if folks are watching this on youtube
otherwise you can find it in the show
notes if you're listening to this
jimmy we have so much to talk about
today so um we're going to talk about
our constant search for meaning and
purpose and significance
we're gonna you're the title of your i'm
sorry the subtitle of your book
rethinking god sex and death in a world
that has lost its mind
we're gonna talk about that now let's
talk about meaning to start now this is
a listener driven
show and so we have some questions from
our audience but i thought we would
start with
talking about meaning our obsession with
meaning what is the meaning of
life and what does meaning even mean in
your book you actually talk about
meaning 1.0 versus meaning 2.0 and also
there's a meaning 3.0
i thought maybe we could start there as
a discussion point
yeah i mean i think the simplest thing
is to realize i think most of us are in
you know what clinicians call [ __ ] or go
blind territory
right now right we're sort of finding
ourselves guard rail to god rail in a
sort of schizophrenic sense of like what
on earth is going on in the world
and and and it's not that we've all gone
crazy
you know the world has so like that
actually in fact uh jay krishnamurti
the indian philosopher famously said he
said it's no
sign of health to be well adjusted to a
society that's sick
so the fact that we're all feeling
stressed feeling anxiety
constantly doom-scrolling our news fees
that's actually a
healthy response to a world that's gone
off the rails
and we all know i mean you know people
use fancy terms like a metacrisis
that we're going on it's not just one
thing right it's not just that we have
political divisions and we're no longer
close and trusting with our neighbors
it's not just that there's potentially
ecological impacts or extreme weather
events that you guys in california us in
texas you know pretty much everywhere in
between have been
experiencing and folks all around the
world have been experiencing it's not
just
um that our global economy and markets
are wildly volatile and you know not
these days people talking about
what sort of recession might we be in
now and is it
v-shaped like a quick bounce off the
bottom and back up to happy times or is
it u-shaped
and then they're like hey guys it might
be k-shaped
and that just means hey everybody if
you're reading this and you don't
understand what k-shaped is you mean
you're already [ __ ]
right so so basically just means you
know the 0.01 percent
managed to harvest an awful lot and
everybody else in the sort of
quote-unquote literally gets put in
quotes the real economy
right not assets not investments not
that kind of thing
end up um struggling harder to stay in
place
so so let's just acknowledge that times
are increasingly intense and
increasingly
complicated and that that can overwhelm
our familiar landmarks and handrails
and when we feel overwhelmed we end up
feeling
stressed isolated alienated separated
so that's kind of like the stuff out
there right and then
most of us you know all humans all
animals we're very efficient creatures
like we are always trying to take
shortcuts to get the
maximum bang for our buck out of a
calorie you know they do all those
studies we're like how far will a
squirrel go from the squirrel feeder to
go grab the nut in the winter you know
or how far will a bird fly to get a seat
and we do the same with decision making
basically
most of our bodily sense the sec lisa
feldman barrett who's got appointments
at northeastern university and at
harvard medical school
wrote a rad book called how emotions are
made and she's basically saying hey you
know all that thing like we've got 37
emotions and you can pick them out on
the micro muscles on your face and that
kind of thing she's like yeah not so
much that's actually
way more culturally constructed than
you'd think you know what kind of
like an american like howdy partner with
big toothy grin might express happiness
but a
tiny upturned corner of a smile in japan
might mean the same thing like
all this kind of stuff but she says hey
actually we interception
is what we have even before emotion and
it's literally what we feel in our guts
our viscera
and basically all we are is a prediction
engine we're just trying to figure out
what to do next
do i need to ramp up do i need to slow
down and she says it's either it's just
one of four things we're either active
or passive
and we're positive or negative right so
like active positive
is i'm happy active passive is i'm
content
you know negative passive is i'm
depressed negative active i'm angry
yeah right and so we're just a
prediction engine right and we're just
constantly trying to figure out do i
need to throttle up throttle down
to get ready for like even if i open the
door like is that a spring-loaded door
how how do i have to pull like all that
so much of our bandwidth is dedicated to
that so we're always trying to take
efficient shortcuts to figure out what
to do next
and the fancy term for that is
heuristics which basically just means
rules of thumb
yeah right if this then that most of the
time right i'm going to look around and
see what everybody else is doing i'm
probably going to go with
do what they do because that's a safe
bet all these kind of moves so
as we're facing this super crazy complex
meta crisis
right and every and the amount of
information we receive
is overwhelming us we look for shortcuts
to figure out
what it all means and the classic way is
to
look to established authorities that are
trustworthy
to tell us right right so this was a
long-ass setup to get to
right meaning 1.0 and meaning 2.0 so
we've kind of had
two pillars of who are the trusted
authorities we've got kind of benign
authority
like basically the secular society we've
got academic institutions
mit harvard stanford those kind of
places supposedly benign
supposedly well yeah we'll get to we'll
get to the collapse right because we've
got
academia we've got the corporate world
the the goldman sachses and the
mckinseys of the world and the place
that all the
high-performing young kids try to get
summer internships right
in school and you know probably kick off
on the rat race you guys stepped off
we've got doctors in the medical
community right we've got all these
we've got news your newscasters think
back to like walter cronkite
you know or bbc radio yeah you know bbc
radio used to pump out around the world
and no matter what happened at the same
time boop
you know good evening and welcome you
know and we're going to tell you exactly
what's going on
and you know no surprise
we have seen the absolute collapsing of
trust and faith in all of those
institutions thrown in silicon valley
right a decade ago everyone would go
like we're going to launch an app and
we're going to make a billion dollars
and we're going to make the world a
better place right buy one give one here
the goal goes and everyone's like yay go
silicon valley
move fast break things and now many of
them actually believe that too
it wasn't yes i think the bloom is
thoroughly off that rose i mean that hbo
show silicon valley right took the piss
out of them thoroughly
and at the time it was sort of edgy
humor right but then you get
2016 you get brexit you get the 2016 u.s
election you get cambridge analytica you
get all of the assessments
our buddy tristan harris who came out
with that uh documentary the social
dilemma
which was all about the corruption of
big tech shashana zubaf
um at harvard wrote surveillance
capitalism you know we're starting to
kind of like
wake up and go oh whoa you know you know
if you're wondering who the product is
and it's free it's you
you know all these kinds of things so
the places we used to go to say well
what's really going on what's a
trustworthy decision
that all that benign authority has been
crumbling
and even throw in doctors right i mean
the doc the idea of
the kind of andy griffith you know like
the what the friendly neighborhood
physician with a little black bag
you know knows the kids delivered them
you know helps them through you know
broken bones that kind of stuff and
you're like wait
that same doctor now has got big pharma
incentives and he's been plying my
little billy with industrial strength
amphetamine since the kid was
six and then that really wrecked him
when he hit adolescence and now he's on
antidepressants and maybe got even
wackier and wiggier and maybe started
getting really volatile so we put him on
antipsychotics too
like this cop you know this shotgun
cocktail
down there and you're like i mean
creating more problems with the
solutions
oh my god i mean the swiss found swiss
committee on bioethics actually
ruled that it was a violation of
children's sovereignty
to be prescribing those kind that those
potent psychoactives
to children in development they don't
have full consent you're like you're
completely wrecking how my nervous
system wires up how my psychology and my
sense of self takes shape
i don't even know what home feels like
because i've never been there
so then you throw in typical adolescents
who am i and what's the point and where
do i go and you're like they don't even
have
zero zero on their grid coordinate right
and then throw in
you know sackler and produce farmer and
the fact that 80 percent of all heroin
acts in america today
started with a prescription for
oxycontin or you know an equivalent
right
so the doctors got them hooked so let's
just say all of these things
right you're like hmm man things were a
lot easier like let's say 1980s back
you know you could you could trust i
can't make sense of this all
but somebody has and they're not far
away
i could pick up the wall street journal
i could pick up the new york times these
are the journals of record
this is the thing right or even
centralized media there are like three
tv stations we all sit down as a family
because there's only one screen in the
whole house it's 7 p.m every day and
then there's mash you know that kind of
thing right
um so we've seen the collapse in that
form of meaning and you could say that's
that's kind of the you know benign
authority that was
modern liberalism and i don't mean
liberal like progressive democrat i mean
like
french enlightenment liberalism like hey
democracy
civil rights private property markets
generally a good thing
everybody's entitled to these rights
that kind of promise
and at the same time we've had a
collapse in
traditional meaning of organized
religion right so
so you know the pew research foundation
i think was probably 2016
maybe they they published for the first
time that
that the the spiritual but not religious
right the n-o-n-es or the nuns
right were the not just the fastest
growing group but now the largest
so you know for all of human history you
pretty much
came up with your people and you came up
with that belief system and it wasn't
mixer match
it wasn't a spiritual cafeteria right it
was like this is who we are this is what
we believe this is our moral code
this is our hierarchy of authority and
this is the way the world works
right and so you have meaning 1.0
traditional religion and you got meaning
2.0
say modern liberalism
1.0 was all about its promise was
salvation if you believe you're saved
right but that promise of salvation came
at the cost of exclusion
if you don't believe what we believe you
are heretical
you're damned to hell are you sure you
or you show not getting to heaven
however we define it
and you might be oppressed while you're
living as well yep and then and then
modern liberalism you know the french
enlightenment all that kind of stuff was
like oh man you know they they lived
through the protestant wars of
reformation in europe they saw all the
bloodshed they saw the superstition this
is the kind of turf that
christopher hitchens and sam harris and
that group that was sort of
called the new atheists yeah you know
right after 9 11 and that kind of stuff
we're saying hey it's time to knock down
that straw man
right um and so that was the promise of
salvation but the cost of exclusion
modern liberalism said look we're going
to
ditch the salvation thing that's super
problematic so we're going to offer
inclusion
all men and women are created equal and
entitled to
right life liberty the pursuit of
happiness but
at the expense of salvation except we're
going to separate church and state
right we're not going to touch that
third rail of meaning
now both of these have obviously fallen
short for us
and you can you can you can critique you
know respectfully
traditional religions just in the sense
of hey they were
almost all formulated hundreds to
thousands of years ago in very different
times places and conditions
the rate volume complexity and just
burden of
awareness and information we have now is
kind of putting those there's stress
cracks on all that system
but then you've also got the corruption
of the institutions you know the
catholic church sexual abuse scandals
all those kind of things have really
really undermined the integrity
of that position but the same thing has
happened right for meaning 2.0 where
you're like well you're like wait a
second this is kind of like
tyler dude and fight club you know the
brad pitt character right where he's
like man we're the middle of we're the
middle
children of history man you know we have
no great war our great war is a
spiritual war we were all raised to
believe we can become rock stars and
presidents you know and
and millionaires and we're not and we're
pissed
now in your book you you called him the
ultimate nihilist
yeah and that was i i don't completely
agree with that i agree with you 80
of the way but i don't think a true
nihilist doesn't take the actions that
tyler durden or you know the the main
character whoever
uh take in the book where they go beyond
simple nihilism where it's throw your
hands up nothing
really matters i mean that's essentially
the stance of the nihilus right
it seems to me he takes it a bit farther
like well you know what maybe
nothing matters but i'm still going to
overthrow this
secular capitalist because to me they're
very similar meaning 1.0 meaning
2.0 in the sense that they're both
pernicious
that because we believe that if we do
something
then we get something and what i mean by
like the
the secular you we we're worshiping an
altar either way
it's the altar of consumerism or it's
the altar of
you know whatever name your religion
ryan grew up jehovah's witness for
example
you know that that's a particular you
know religion that that
there was a there was a set of dogma and
i think either one of those has
has a dogma but with the tyler durden
thing um
i don't know i'm almost i find that type
of nihilism
appealing in a way so maybe talk me out
of that
well i mean in the sense that what that
they were looking at he was doing the
soap
bombs to take down the financial
institutions to be clear i don't think
violence is the answer
no sure well i mean so so
there is you're actually teeing up this
is a dog leg into a
awesome conversation so i'm happy to
have it which is which is
what happens when our polite fictions
collapse around us
right and we realize that in fact all
that we've been told and
sold was effectively a bill of goods and
that reality is just kind of wysiwyg
all day long like what we see is what we
get and nobody promised us a rose garden
right right and most folks
back away in fact uh terence mckenna's
brother dennis
right has has an awesome book title of
his
life with his brother and it's called
the brotherhood of the screaming abyss
right which awesome title but the notion
that that that screaming abyss
waits for anybody who is actually
sincere and willing to look
deep enough yeah right which is what is
like reality
unvarnished and unmediated by comforting
just so
stories about what it all means you know
like that amy um
what's that what's her name why am i
spacing the uh the comic the blonde
haired comic
schumer schumer right she she did one of
those she did like i don't know some
short series and it was like you know
two la girls on their
exercise bikes talking about the
universe and what the universe wants
she's like yeah i really think the
universe wants me to bang my boss even
though he's married you know like
with just that idea of like like i take
really kind of lazy comfort
in in a store in an explanatory
mechanism that tells me the
way the way it all works out and it's
generally puts me in the center of it
and it's generally
happily ever after yeah right so so we
get
past all that and you get to that
screaming abyss
and you know like camus said it
in his book the myth of sisyphus he said
the only serious question in life
is whether or not to commit suicide yeah
yeah right and that's that's the abyss
that is like oh my god i was born
a monkey with clothes i am blessed and
cursed
with an awareness of past present and
future and my own pending morality which
as far as we know is unique in the
animal kingdom
right i mean the two things like god sex
and death right the idea like
you could make a case that we are the
only
animal that is aware of all three for
the majority of our life if you think
about animals like sexuality which
consumes
human consciousness for you know large
percentages of our day you just look at
pornography online and the number of
hits the number the amount of bandwidth
the number of dollars spent towards it
religion right and everything from
plastic surgery to nursing homes to
anything we try and do to avoid
death and dying like most animals are
like i'm just trying to stay alive
eat and not be eaten and then once a
month or once a season or once every
couple of years
heat happens and then all we think about
we're consumed about
procreating for a day a week a month and
then boom it's over and behind us
and until maybe like two days before i
die like a rogue elephant
and it's time to wander off into the
into the bush by myself to lay down my
bones
i'm just here doing my thing seeking
pleasure it's it's
taking pleasure avoiding prism to a
great extent yeah
avoiding pain in fact i would say that
we're not seeking pleasure we're always
avoiding pain
especially when we are seeking pleasure
we're doing that to avoid pain we're
running from misery
i do want to dive a lot more into that
before we do that because you have a
topic uh
hedonic engineering so we're gonna we're
gonna get into that but this is a
listener driven show so let me let me
get to a question from
mike in illinois it strikes me that
maybe if you're if you're living your
life um like you guys are like a lot of
others are like i'm trying to do
about adding adding value to your life
in your possessions and in your
relationships
and all that you do does it become too
self-centered have you guys felt that
temptation to
focus on what's bringing value to you
not what's bringing value to others
so ryan i you know this question comes
up so
we'll provide some context for jamie so
we
often talk about as minimalists
everything that we do or own serves
a purpose or brings us joy in some way
now joy is a is a loaded word just like
the word god is a loaded word right
um when we talk about joy we're often
talking about our experience with
other people not just my own pleasure my
own happiness my own contentment even
right joy goes beyond the self joy also
makes enough room for other emotions it
makes room for grief
and sorrow and mourning and sadness and
anger
uh so when we're talking about joy
that's what we're talking about in terms
of
a definition if you want to call it that
so when someone like mike
asked this question that's why i thought
it was the perfect the perfect place
that
to ask this question he is sort of
talking about a a nihilism like
well if i'm living a life that
only adds value to me then yeah there is
a
self-centeredness to that and he's
asking whether or not it's selfish i
guess
my quick answer to that is there is a
difference between being self-interested
and selfish
selfish would be making decisions that
are at the detriment of
the people of other people but being
self-centered is yeah we're
to some extent we're all self-centered
right yeah i mean i think well
we have the capacity to be and if you i
mean it's a little word play but i think
it can be helpful which is
you know you could make a case that
being selfish is
it's me and mine right that old pink
floyd tune like i'm all right jack
keep your hands off my stash so so yeah
that's probably
anti-social but being self-centered
being actually centered in oneself
right is the non-negotiable first
step in expanding care concern and
ultimately
service and so absolutely i think what's
super critical
as folks are wrestling these days was
like wait you know to the point of the
caller
right well wait if i just seek to
optimize my best life
like is that it that feels kind of maybe
slightly hollow
and yeah vapid and and it's i think
just critical to pan back historically
and be like you know
no humans ever have ever thought this
was okay
right basically and if you take a look
in fact tim wu is one of my
no humans ever thought what is okay that
it's all about me
but there are ascetics who go live in a
cave for seven years
is that all about them or is there some
greater good there
well i mean i think if we look to
history you can see how did people
attempt to
break the mortal coil right break the
grind
of like life is nasty brutish and short
right how do we attain something and for
a long long time
some of the only ways to do that were to
absent yourself to remove yourself from
the grind it's why monasteries existed
right right and if you even think about
in monasteries right pretty much around
the world regardless of tradition
you know poverty chastity and humility
were almost they were they're consistent
vows right why
because money sex and power
are mind [ __ ] and if you try and play
with those and find god you're almost
never going to make it to your
destination yeah yeah right so
there was you know basically how do we
exclude ourselves how do we remove
ourselves
from this total train wreck that's super
confusing
and there's not enough to go around and
you know and we're likely to get stormed
or
you know or in conflicts et cetera so
let's just it's almost like they were
removing themselves from these selfish
endeavors yeah well and and then the
question becomes okay
modern the you know modern west
consumerism all these kind of things
we're like oh now
we are trying to sort of we're not doing
the monastic path we're in the world we
have families we have relationships we
have work in the world now how do we do
it all
right how do we do it all with earning
an income
with relationships and sexuality with
power fame you know every you know
instagram
influencer like all these little these
these extra bits and that makes it way
more complicated
but that fellow tim who's who's the guy
who coined
the term net neutrality for the internet
he wrote two books that have shaped my
thinking
profoundly on all this one is um
the master switch which is all about any
information platform
from telegraph to radio to tv now to
internet and he's like hey they always
start out
democratic in utopia and think
blockchain think nfts these days think
any of these things
they always end up hegemonic and
centrally controlled so just watch that
but his other one is called the
attention merchants and it's this
fascinating study of
marketing in the late 19th to through
the 20th century
and fascinatingly the like three to
three or four
like guiding lights that shaped all
marketing in the 20th century that led
to mad men that led to all the things
we're familiar with
they were they were evangelical
preachers slash literal snake oil
salesman like they were actually doing
that
wow and so you so you have this
conflation
of our religious and spiritual
aspirations with consumer products into
the 20s
right we've commodified that which is
not commodifiable we try to commodify
love
religion sex yeah and we do it i mean
it's i mean a little bit uh
tongue-in-cheek we start the show with
advertisements suck we're brought to you
by nobody
because i i'm well aware of the
temptations ryan and i have gone through
that
that it'd be really easy to sell out for
a seven-figure sort of thing but
what if you lose all your freedom what
have you really gained
yeah absolutely and and so you know to
your caller's question
that that's the first point is just to
understand the last hundred years of
what we've been told and sold
the perfectability of you yes right if
you can just acquire all the things even
like
biohacking you know the question is like
okay so once you become bulletproof
what bullets do you step in front of on
behalf of whom
that's good read that podcast sean right
like like what is
and if you look around the world every
spiritual tradition that's had access to
some ecstatic peak state some profound
epiphany has always come directly
coupled to
service and caring concern so karma yoga
seva christian charity and good works
you name it
around the world there's always been the
sense of this is not about you cupcake
right this is about all of us bigger
picture longer game yes and
and you know and psychologists have
modeled this as well the hedonic
treadmill right the idea that chasing
happiness doesn't actually get you
happiness chasing purpose and mean your
fault pursuing purpose and meaning
which involves and requires connection
to
others right becomes the non-negotiables
so it so even like david brooks i'm in
the new york times
right he wrote that book the second
mountain a couple years ago
i didn't either but i read enough pieces
on it i'm kind of familiar with the
concept
the first mountain is all the bells you
know the brass rings material consumer
success and the second mountain is
meaning
so he makes this kind of great centra
centrist conservative americana norman
rockwell kind of pitch for
let's you know let's all keep on
striving
for that second mountain of like meaning
and purpose but the reality is is that
first mounds [ __ ]
and never existed it was a molehill that
was constructed
to sell us on the illusion and delusion
and then you throw in like you got
evangelical
origins of 20th century marketing to get
to mad men
then you get the 60s and you get the
influx of eastern religion and
specifically the emphasis on
interiority enlightenment all of these
groovy groovy things
and there's been so i think some really
compelling critiques
and then you know and then that begets
the secret and the new age and all you
know and our whole personal growth space
and some critiques of that of being like
this is sort of mixed spirituality
right the fact that you know all of
these ideas of like thoughts become
things or i shape my reality you get
this unholy marriage of
eastern sort of vedanta right which is a
little bit like hey the world is
illusory and it's only in our mind and
we change our mind and then reality
changes i mean that's a gross
simplification but just kind of at the
basic
coupled with and i'm a
well-conditioned programmed consumer
rationalist individual and i've been and
i've been raised to believe it's all
about me and i can grow up to be an
astronaut or president
right and i deserve best life big house
nice car and if i can't i'm going to
rent them for my instagram videos
right and you merge those two and you
end up with this
toxic stew of like bourgeois
gnosticism yes and so
it seems to me that narcissism
correlates to get back to the nihilism
discussion
really well with nihilism in a way it it
doesn't seem like it would at first but
there
it seems to me like they're almost uh
they're almost just tied together or
maybe they're even the same thing at
some point
yeah i mean they they are i would i
guess they feel to me like
they're both sort of unstable elements
you know like
they're prone to collapse so if i i get
a very strong
sugar high i get comfort i get certainty
i get temporary self-esteem
if i really do believe that it is all
about me right if i shrink the way you
know and i'm in charge of everything
and then when that bubble inevitably
pops and why does it pop
well because i just i mean back to you i
mean i love the fact that
um your guys podcast and entire stance
is
minimalism right because effectively
this this whole
book is what is the minimalist approach
yes what is the
what is the most anti-fragile
baseline reality that can survive con or
baseline philosophy
that can survive adverse contact with
reality
and not crack yeah right so so
i mean the fact that obviously whether
this is john duns no man is an island
you know or mike tyson's everybody's got
a plan to get hit right
like just it's not all about us and the
idea that i am 100 responsible for
shaping my reality is
obviously called swallow because you
just have to you know
anybody in fact there's this awesome
woman she's a theologian at duke
and she wrote a book she came down with
cancer at the same time that she was
researching
pentecostal faith healing communities
okay right and that's actually why i
found her because i was
doing research on religion for this guy
wrote the book blessed
yes yeah yes okay exactly and we were
going to have her on the podcast but it
didn't work out but she's actually
scheduled in the future
oh fantastic yeah she's wonderful and a
funny writer yeah and
and this really you know touching story
of her own like
small child coming down and she was
actually a member of a canadian
mennonite community so she came out of
like like horse and buggy
territory into an academic perspective
but long story short
she comes down with cancer and everybody
that she's interviewing in these church
communities start just
puking on her all this well-intentioned
stuff of like and so the book title is
everything happens for a reason
and other lies i've loved yes right and
she just
deconstructs that notion and it shows up
in both
orthodox community but it also shows up
in the new age and the self-help space
which is this this utter fiction
that if i change my mind i change my
reality and that
works incredibly well for the
bourgeois worried well if my number one
problem is i've got all this [ __ ] but
i'm just still a little neurotic
then changing my mindset changes my life
right right but then you're like what
about
child soldiers in rwanda yes right what
about
the bottom four billion humans on this
planet that are suffering
and we say just declutter you'll be fine
right exactly
just throw all your stuff away well i
mean and you know so back to the
nihilism narcissism thing
um something i haven't wrapped my head
around this enough to have like a
considered position but i have
definitely noticed a few
like data points that are kind of i find
deeply concerning
and one is folks who are in that new age
spirituality space and we're seeing kind
of the rise
with q anon and and pandemic and all
these kind of
mash-up meta conspiracies right right
that i have heard people say like
well-intentioned people i know
say oh you know when i've asked that
kind of a question like
so back to the idea that we are we've
been sold a bill of goods we've been
conditioned as rational consumer
individuals within the bigger context of
you know modern western liberalism
neoliberalism and that's kind of been a
racket
one of the things in india and there's
critiques that are showing up more
strongly now with black lives matter
with critical race theory
hey it's not just about individuals
right there's actually systemic
structural things that are going on and
at what point does our emphasis on our
own perfectability
right absolve us or numb us to our
responsibility to a
broader civic commitment or connection
or humanity
and so i've you know i've had people say
oh those child soldiers in rwanda this
is
in meanwhile in a gorgeous you know
three million dollar you know
house in the hill country overlooking
austin you'd be like oh well
well those child soldiers in rwanda hmm
well i think it must have been that they
chose to incarnate as that in this
lifetime because they needed they needed
the contrast for their soul growth
dismiss that person immediately though
yeah yeah well i mean you just you know
and gut wrenching you're like
you cannot be serious because what does
this let you do by the way it lets you
still sit there
on your meditation cushion with your
bath salts and your and your and your
binaural beats
doing exactly [ __ ] nothing differently
and convincing yourself and i've also
heard lately
folks even had a name for it they're
like oh um
we're not con this again this is you
know
affluent left of center progressive
folks but within the kind of
psychedelic renaissance country culture
personal growth space
saying oh really you know
and this is not to hold off on pandemic
stuff don't want to touch it but in
general they say they're saying
hey as long as we keep our vibes high as
long as we have access to the
supplements and the peptides and the
various things that keep our immune
systems up
and as long as we are healthy vital
active and thinking good thoughts
we're actually pretty good we're pretty
bulletproof on this we're going to make
our way through
and then and this kind of then dovetails
with like evolutionary spirituality like
barbara max hubbard and some of those
ones who are like hey
there's going to be this split in
humanity right not everyone's going to
make it
the folks that are most conscious or
will will vibrate to the fifth density
or to the pleiades or whatever
fill in the blank right some peace out
you know awesome move that leaves this
train wreck safely behind
and there's going to be a k-shaped right
rapture
which is and they even call them the
cobbies like
the poor overweight type 2 diabetes
folks who are eating processed and
refined sugars
aren't keeping their vibes high who are
going to get culled
by this virus or whatever comes next and
you're like
whoa whoa whoa whoa like just stop right
there
because like if you think through the
input the ethical implications of what
you've just said
right yeah right it basically says we
are going to
dissociate from our moral and ethical
responsibility
for the most vulnerable humans on this
earth
and we're going to write them off as you
know
evolutionary grist for the mill
so that we can keep living our high vibe
life
and make it through the portal this is
conjuring images of
um remember that remember a silence of
the lambs
for whatever reason like because what
you're describing the way that you're
describing it
i'm picturing people who don't realize
they're evil
doing very evil things like buffalo bill
didn't think he was an evil person
sure even though he was the most evil
yeah it puts the lotion in the basket
sort of thing
and like he didn't see himself as evil
yeah and and um now obviously i think
there's a difference there he was
intentionally harming someone what
what we're talking about is like a harm
through
omission of action or something that's
the cliche you know the the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions i mean when you're talking
what you were just talking about
makes me think about religion and any
other
because what you're talking about is a
philosophy that people use to
throw their hands in the air with the
world and say well as long as i'm doing
x y and z
it doesn't matter about whoever else
it's their own fault that they don't
have the understanding that i have
yes and any philosophy or religion it
has it's that mechanism it's the
it's the easy pill to take to say yeah
here's the easy answer to life and now i
can absolve myself like what jehovah's
witness is what really
christianity in general kind of uh is
frustrating or any
end time doomsday type religion
is that their the whole philosophy is
this world is doomed
there's nothing that we can do to solve
it so uh all we can do is sit here
and follow these specific rules and then
jesus is gonna come back or the pro
whoever is gonna come back and there's
gonna be some magic wand
waved that fixes everything yeah and
and fixes it for me and mine yeah so
therefore we're not actually worried and
that's
you know so you've just kind of laid out
very nicely like that structure for
sort of rapture ideologies which is you
know a very like thumbs down on
existence but there's a there's a
gateway portal inflection point coming
soon and we can kind of see it from here
if we squint
and everybody on the other side that is
part of our tribe or group
comes up roses we're actually better off
on the other side of that yeah
therefore let's pin it and head right
off that cliff no
never mind the skidmarks and and never
mind the collateral damage of what we're
leaving behind and and
most of us when we think are like a
rapture ideology you think that's like
wired up to suicide vest you're wearing
like a sandwich board you know saying
the end is nigh like you know and it's
easy to kind of dismiss that it's like
oh those backwards ass folks right
um but it's not right we have we have
techno-utopian raptures we have you know
we're all going to upload our
consciousness to computers or we're
going to have
brain implants or we're going to
disappear to you know we're going to
have space colonies on the moon or moss
and all of them are one percenter
solutions yeah they all filter one
percent differently
this is the saved and the dam this is
the high net worth this is the beautiful
people this is the meritocratic talented
these are the patriots versus the
communists take your peg but once you
once you kind of peel back that layer
and you're like oh
this is actually a structural
philosophical framework
and it shows up across politics
economy culture industries you're like
oh whoa now you see them everywhere
and once you see them everywhere you
realize none of them actually pencil out
they're all actually
sociopathic you know because they are
all saying
once again we make a hairline crack
between care for all of humanity and
saving our own skins and and to your
point i mean and i hope
by the way i hope that conversation
about narcissism and nihilism now
ties up right we've just talked about
those folks making because as we
experience cognitive dissonance
the pressure to make a lunge to gain the
false certainty of one of those rapture
ideologies to wrap ourselves in that
warm fuzzy blanket which says hey
whatever big time scary bad things
that's gonna happen is happens
we come up roses so the the pull of
cultic
community is overwhelmingly strong and
we're even seeing this
um in movies like in our storytelling so
you i mean i noticed
what's what's the name of the sequel to
the da vinci code
do you remember whatever that is angels
and demons yes
oh it could be almost like the prequel
maybe but yeah it was the one where
basically the the anti-hero in fact
they're all anti-heroes now they're not
just mustache twizzling
villains right it's a tech bro who
decides in fact he's run the numbers
society doesn't pencil out so he's going
to do some bio-terror attack or
something to cull
humanity in order to save the rest right
you look at black
panther right the bad guy in black
panther was wildly sympathetic
actually his critique of society was
bang on yeah
right and the same with thanos so
so like you know in the same way that we
had the sopranos and we had mad men you
know and we had breaking bad
we had the rise of the anti-hero and
prestige tv yeah we're now seeing the
rise of the apocalyptic anti-hero
in our big stories because the idea is
like and the question is is like
they might not be wrong the question is
is just
is that a you know final solutions
uh have a dubious track record yes right
and and i'm even experiencing this um
in real time in the world with
some of the people that are supposed to
be on team
human so folks with you know
bleeding edge comp competence in quantum
computing
ai crispr gene editing bioterror these
kind of things and you're fine
and you know god bless them a lot of
them are spectrum-y as [ __ ]
right they're they're they're they are
misfit toy
rain men and rain women yeah often rain
men
you know and as their emotional
overload and overwhelm increases the
the very skill set that leaves them most
capable of helping could also be
turned to the dark right
with the most catastrophic effect
without them even realizing it possibly
yeah i mean if you know again it's the
form of being
of being um compassionate in a perverse
way
all you have to do is have absolute
clarity in your calculations
right to conclude that all of us are
doomed if we do nothing
therefore any action to save at least
some of us will be the noble choice
that's it mike let me send you a copy of
jamie's book it's called recapture the
rapture i do want to move on very
quickly to our lightning round i know
we're running out of time ryan so let's
let's do this before we get over to the
the maximal yeah we got a question here
from coffee breath conversations which i
believe is a
name of a podcast but they they sent us
a uh a tweet
i believe it says how does one find
meaning after a close
loved one has passed and they are
struggling to deal
with the passing well here's what we try
to do i'll give you a pithy answer less
than 140 characters
you don't actually have to do that you
can monitor on a bit we'll tweeze out
something beautiful or at least podcast
sean will he'll put it in the show notes
here's my pithy answer for you suffering
is not the way but it illuminates the
path toward a more meaningful life
before we started recording jamie i was
telling you a bit of our backstory
listeners of this podcast know it well
they've seen it in our netflix
documentaries like my mom died my
marriage ended created a great amount of
suffering in my life
but that suffering was rather
eye-opening for me as well and it
doesn't
it's not necessary you know ryan had a
different type of suffering going on in
his life but quite often we recognize
that suffering
we don't want it to linger but it does
often illuminate the path
forward for us do you talk about that at
all
yeah i mean ultimately you know no no
one gets out of here alive
yeah right and acquainting ourselves
with that is is
radically important and um
there's an idea that you know basically
we should learn to to weep
rather than whimper we're so obsessed
with our microaggressions and micro
transgressions and triggers and you know
and
and and safety and honestly it's like
grow the [ __ ] up
humans like it's ever been thus and this
is as good as it's ever been
right so so so as we experience like
that the tragedy of loss of loved ones
those kind of things
open to it you know martine prechtel
who's uh who's a mayan elder and he's a
poet he's a profoundly
rooted dude has he's got a beautiful
line he says grief is praise
it is the way our love honors what it
misses
that's beautiful you know and alice
walker says my heart's been broken open
so many times
it just swings open wide now like a
suitcase
right yeah so let's do that let's let's
weep let's drop to our [ __ ]
knees racked with sobs right and honor
what we love and what we miss amen it's
funny he says that because
i i didn't acknowledge those emotions
for most
my mom died when i was 28 and it was the
first time i cried in my adult life
so like there's a literal weeping and
there's also the metaphorical weeping
and and
being open to those emotions and part of
that i think was a cultural
meme of men behave a particular way
providers behave a particular way
and and so what do we do we simply
repress
reality in a way we we're we're we're
hiding reality
in order to put forth the the norman
rockwell painting of
in which are beautiful but it's not
reality and if we can acknowledge
two things like there's a beautiful
painting here but i can't pretend this
is also
the way things are quote-unquote
supposed to be we're gonna get a lot
more into what how things are supposed
to be ryan do you have something pithy
for us
yeah uh my fifth answer is this
compassion is the antidote to suffering
so i think whenever someone is suffering
or sees
someone suffering they need to be
compassionate or seek
compassion i mean i think that's
ultimately what anyone in this situation
would need
it's funny you talk about the you you
said the thing about
none of us get out of here alive and
it's funny how
you know being raised as a jehovah's
witness like everything comes back to
that for me
i i understood this no one no one makes
it out of here alive but because of the
training the teachings it was no one's
made it out of here alive
so far it's and it's crazy how like
in a way it's really great that some
people have that mentality
that they're trying to seek okay how can
how can some of us make it out of here
alive
i mean i admire that um but there's like
a really nice
i don't know there's something that
really is peaceful
when i finally accepted the oh [ __ ] like
no one has made it out of here life
yeah and yeah what makes me any
different you remind me
i don't know if you ever read this uh
eddie murphy when he was 21 years old he
did this
like hilarious op-ed he was convincing
people they
not to die like we haven't died so far
and i don't plan on dying today all you
have to do is not die today and then
tomorrow will come as long as you don't
die tomorrow and it keeps
this bit going and of course like that
maps out until or maps on reality until
it doesn't
but um yeah with with there's almost a
metaphor there ryan with the
the no one makes it out of here alive
but
but you know when you talk about some of
the mystics in your book as well but
i think mystics sort of make it out of
here alive in a way like they don't keep
living but they were living like they
were truly
living in a way that most of us
only pretend to through our instagram
accounts
we got a bunch more to talk about but
first ryan what do we got
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners check them
out
hey this is jenna from salt lake city
okay i grew up in a fairly religious
family
um and my mother has always been a
really good
example to me of this um i've had
several family members make decisions
that
were contrary to what my parents values
were
and what i've seen from my mom is that
um
she always follows the advice that she
got from
the movie bambi uh flower the skunk uh
his mother would tell him if he can't
say something nice then he shouldn't say
anything at all
and um that is my mom and she can't say
something nice about something she just
won't say anything at all
but the other thing that she does or the
other things that she does
um she'll find things that she agrees
with this person on
and they'll talk about that or if they
have common interests they'll talk about
that and if she can't find something
like that that's kind of a neutral topic
to discuss
then she'll ask questions about that
person's interests
what are you doing right now how is your
work going how are your hobbies going
what do you do
you know how skiing how's hiking how's
whatever you're doing
um she never volunteers advice she will
only give advice and this
pretty much goes across the board with
all her kids but she'll only give advice
if we specifically ask for it she never
calls us up and says hey i've been
thinking about this problem and i think
you should do this this mess
she never never volunteers advice um i
currently am dealing with a similar
situation from a parental perspective
we adopted a child as a teenager and
their values are very different than
ours are and so there are some things
you know house rules-wise we don't want
them to do drugs or whatever but
basically i followed the same sort of
thing
if i can't say something nice i don't
say anything at all i don't volunteer
advice on her life choices unless she
asks me
and she's 18 now so that's less and less
common
but when we talk we find things that we
agree on we talk about music a lot
because we share the same
um same uh likes and dislikes and music
so
i hope that's helpful to you and to your
callers
hey my name is sarah i am in san
francisco
so last week i still had facebook and a
friend from high school that i have not
hung out with really since middle school
let's say
but she went to my high school wrote
something that i felt was
wrong whatever on facebook and i never
respond because i hate those things
but i decided to unlike it because it
was very offensive to uh
my life and then i was like you know
what i'll just unfollow her
she doesn't even know i'm following her
anyway but i didn't realize she saw my
unlike thing
anyway i get this huge message on
facebook about
um how she can't believe i'm not her
friend anymore because of this
comment she said so i just wrote back
like hey just so you know like i'm cool
being friends
i just didn't want to be your facebook
friend so if that's cool too and then
she was kind of like
was thrown off by that we ended up
having this really good conversation on
there
um and then actually the next day i
decided you know i'm just gonna delete
facebook altogether
um kind of like i heard ryan discuss not
having facebook so i don't have facebook
now and it's so
freeing and it's so funny how quickly
you find out who your real friends are
um and i talked to my husband about this
and i feel like this would go along with
everything you guys say
um we don't have the power to be
omnipresent
um and that's been a huge problem with
social media is that
if you use it the wrong way you feel
like you are omnipresent you know every
news story you know everybody's problems
you have to see everybody's vacations
and it's like you're everywhere at the
same time
we don't have the capability of handling
that pressure
as humans and i i keep thinking that i
do
and then i go back online and i realize
i do not um and there's a guilt even
associated with that with news stories
and all these horrible things happening
like why can't i
why can't i handle all this like why
don't i want to read and know what's
happening well because it's just
i can't be omnipresent i can't um
physically do it or spiritually or
emotionally
all right y'all thanks again to jamie
wheel for joining us today you can check
out his new book
it is called recapture the rapture you
can find all the information a bunch of
free resources
as well at recapturetherapture.com we'll
put a link to that in the show notes
we'll also put a link to whatever else
jamie is working on
right now real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life
of the minimalists speaking of books
ryan and i have a book coming out this
summer
we do i better get to work
it's called love people use things i
just finished the eighth
draft of it it's the never ending book
there was 868 edits to this draft and
it's funny because i remember with our
last book everything that remains there
was nine drafts
and some of them are way more robust
than others right
but what i realized with this new one is
like oh finally got the process down
this will just be like three
four drafts yeah and here we are
eight giraffes later every yeah
well we got really lucky with i feel
like uh with like minimalism
a documentary about the important things
with
minimalism how to live a meaningful life
those things went really smoothly and it
just set us up with the wrong
expectations of how these things should
go
yeah yeah although i'm so grateful for
the time that we had because
i think we spent more time not i think i
know for a fact we spent more time on
this book
than we have on any of our other books
and it shows
and and so it's called love people use
things you can find it right now
lovepeopleusethings.net that's where you
can pre-order the book you can also
watch the beautiful trailer
that jordan put together also it will be
available on audiobook
we're reading the audiobook i'm just
going to throw this out there for people
listening to this who
aren't a patreon uh patrons
yeah who who aren't patrons who don't
subscribe to our patreon uh who want to
support us
to go and pre-order this book is a great
way to support us um but if you don't
want to support us that's okay too we're
just happy you're here
yes indeed well real quick for our added
value this week ryan
usually we have peter doran singing the
theme song
every little thing yeah and he put out
his first song
in six years yeah
it's called nothing under the sun it's
awesome i thought it was perfect for
this
episode because we've talked about
finding meaning today we're in
on the maximal episode we're gonna talk
about finding meaning a whole lot deeper
as well but
really i think you can sum this up in
music very well and so
we're going to play you out today with
nothing new under the sun
from peter doran by the way we have a
bunch more surprise questions this week
like
how do we rediscover meaning in a
formerly
meaningful relationship that tells me
that it was
meaningful and it's no longer meaningful
we've lost a sense
of meaning right also what's the point
does any of this even matter ryan
dude i can't believe we're about to get
to the answer
to what is the meaning of life
there's only one way to find out that
answer we're also going to talk to jamie
about
his 10 commandments he calls them 10
suggestions for a
more meaningful life and a whole bunch
more questions about
meaning and purpose and a lot more
discussion with jamie wheel and if you
want to hear all that
join us on the minimalist private
podcast this week that's right
we release a private podcast episode
every thursday over on patreon
visit the minimalists.com support to
subscribe and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast app
by the way you also get access to all of
our archives
more minimalism than you can ever listen
to
over there at aboutminimalists.com
support you can follow the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram at the
minimalist if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at the
minimalists.com and if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email
a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
and if you leave here today with just
one message let it be this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye